dann kaufen sie am boden steht und das
ist effizient ja einen tieferen sinn von
ordnung sogar eine schönheit der ordnung
entdeckt der deutsche künstler
maximilian prüfer und war man höre und
staune in den bewegungen von infekten
[Musik]
außergewöhnlich abstrakt und zugleich
bei täglich die muster der natur sind
ein faszinosum regentropfen scheinen wie
einschusslöcher ameisen spuren gleich in
einem gewebe die natur als agierende
kräfte für den deutschen künstler
maximilian prüfer ist die natur keine
mut sondern hauptakteur
[Musik]
es ist effekten ganz realistisches
abbild naturalistisches schon fast aber
wirkt so abstrakt dass es nicht
verstehen können oft als ungeziefer
stegmann jährigen spielen insekten in
prüfers werk eine bedeutende rolle
[Musik]
die insekten haben nur geringen eigenen
willen prüfer versucht ihr verhalten zu
visualisieren sichtbar werden die
bewegungen durch eine ganz feine
beschichtung auf papier die so sensibel
ist dass ich schließlich schläge ab mich
fasziniert mich natürlich ich bin teil
dieser dieser natur und in unserem
kulturellen unserer kulturellen prägung
sind wir sozusagen ausgelagert wie sehen
die natur als umwelt also etwas das uns
umkreist und sehen uns nicht teil davon
also ich versuche mich sozusagen mit
teilen dieser welt zu begreifen
und eben diese welt auf meinen
möglichkeiten aus meiner wahrnehmung
heraus und ein stück weit zu begreifen
aber warum können wir menschen etwas
bekanntes die einen regentropfen nicht
erkennen erst bei genauerem hinsehen
erfolgt eine einordnung sind eher
gleichgültig oder haben wir das gefühl
für die kreis verloren
maximilian kieffer sensibilisiert oder
weiter die wahrnehmung
auf regentropfen entsteht ein universum
das tier als künstler die natur als
konzept bringt auf papier was bereits da
ist und verdeutlicht damit auch das
verhältnis zwischen mensch und tier
[Musik]
ich versuche den menschen hat dieses
hoheitliche wesen der sich sozusagen
auch abbrechen von der tierwelt wieder
zusammenzuführen also das ist eben diese
unterscheidung tier und mensch dass die
in unserem verhalten wieder angeglichen
wird nicht weil ich irgendwie den
menschen abwerten will sondern weil ich
eigentlich darauf aufmerksam machen wir
das eben auch prozesse bei uns gibt und
verhaltensweisen die wir nicht
kontrollieren können instinkte wo wir
angreifbar sind manipulierbar sind und
die will ich eben leichter zugänglich
machen
eine ordnung von der natur geschaffen
[Musik]
die schöne ordnung der natur lässt sich
natürlich auch viel